is that Buffy the Vampire Slayer sarah
michelle gellar made a surprise
appearance in the Big Bang Theory's
series finale just to be clear this
isn't a date yeah I know why are you
holding the special one-hour episode
kicked off with a big twist as Sheldon
and Amy won the Nobel Prize but there
was an even bigger bang what if I'm
dreaming the long-running comedy
included plenty of firsts in their last
episode
[Applause]
Howard and Bernadette's kids appeared on
screen Raj gays Amy a fresh new look and
fans got to see the one thing we've been
waiting 12 years to see game Valier they
finally fix the elevator we also
discovered there's another Big Bang baby
on the way someone's gonna figure it out
when we just tell people oh it's too
early I haven't you wrap my head around
it I have my head is wrap something else
have been wrapped wouldn't be in this
situation excuse me if I recall you're
the one who went out drinking with
Sheldon that came home and attacked me
attacked you I think I said do you wanna
yeah and even Sheldon is pleased with
the news I was there the moment Leonard
and Penny met he said to me that their
babies would be smart and beautiful and
now that they're expecting I have no
doubt that that will be the case thanks
Sheldon a I haven't told my parents yet
but
and penny you're good with how she ends
up you're good frilled I'm thrilled with
her her ending yet beginning it's a
beautiful there's not anything
catastrophic it's just beautiful
I need the characters we're gonna live
on and you're in your mind's and in your
hearts and I think that's what is so
special about it it's really touching
[Music]